[Music]
marcy joins us up next in jackson
mississippi marcy welcome to the show
hey guys it's so cool to get to talk to
y'all
we are honored to talk to you how can we
help today
i've got a weird question i'm gonna give
you a little bit of background otherwise
it's gonna sound kind of crazy
marcy this is what we do for a living
just bring it
all right well my husband was delivered
from 20 years of drug addiction and has
been cleaned for three years wow um yes
god's restored our broken family but our
finances are still pretty broken
um during his act of addiction he would
take unnecessary er visits he would take
out payday loans
um it's just
just messed us up so now we're ready to
clean up the mess together
um we don't know what he owes because no
one's actively collecting and he had
hidden the bills and destroyed a lot so
i have no idea i have an idea
and the number scares me because when i
checked a few years ago it was
i mean we're heading up toward two
hundred thousand dollars
um so can i ask
why didn't you all deal with it then
he was still in active addiction um he
was still hemorrhaging money out of our
family um we separated soon after that
and i went into survival mode good deal
good for you
good for you where are you guys at today
as it stands financially
um i am working he
turned in very last paper for his
seminary degree today
um
he will be looking for a teaching job
asap um i went full time well he's he
wants to do college he wants to go for
his phd but he wants to be teaching too
uh he he agrees that he needs to be
contributing to the finances
yes i could i agree too we all agree on
that yeah and um it's going to be very
difficult to find
just a college teaching job right out of
the gate so
he's going to need to have another plan
and i'm coming from the college world
okay i've hired a number of people
through that system it's going to be a
tough [ __ ] sled it's going to be a tough
sledding ahead so he might want to find
a high school teaching job you want to
find another job that he can do in the
meantime while he's sending out resumes
like school starts next week or in two
weeks across the country and so faculty
hiring is on a cycle and he's probably
looking at next year before he would
land even a part-time gig
yeah
yeah he also builds computers so he's
looking at stuff like that he's helped
looking for jobs building web pages and
um kind of checking out adjunct
positions for january good deal that's
wise right there there you go so what is
the current debt that you know of that
you guys have as a household
as a household i know for sure that
together we owe about sixty five
thousand uh probably want
no probably eighty-five thousand student
loans with his stuff
and then um
mine and the kids medical is going to
run probably under a thousand
as far as what i know for sure i mean
when i added up all of his bills back in
2017
it
it was hard to figure it out because
some of the bills would come in
and they would be like adding on to a
previous bill
so i tried to weed all that out but when
i finished adding it all up plus the
student loans on his side it was around
150. i know it's higher than that now do
you still have any of those bills
i don't when we separated i packed it
all up in a box and i handed it to him
and
um i don't care what you do with it but
you know where those bills came from
right you know hey it was from this
hospital it was from this lender yeah
okay right well i know which hospitals i
don't know
they'll have sold it by now
they'll have sold it to some debt
collector at some point
so i would start there of what you know
and go to all those lenders go to the
hospital and say hey i want to make sure
that we our accounts are clean can you
look up our name let us know you know
bring any documentation because you guys
have nothing and so what you need right
now is to try to find all the
documentation you can find from all
these places to find get a real picture
of what this adds up to because some of
it may have disappeared into the ether
they may have written it off i'd go pull
a credit report on all three credit
reports
too and they're going to tell you what
outstanding debts you have what other
companies are claiming you owe them and
you can pull those for free i believe it
was once a year they may have increased
that to where you can pull it anytime
with covet stuff but you can definitely
pull those for free i would do that on
both of you to get a real picture of
what is out there as far as
documentation
okay that would be my first plan uh you
also have the pile of debt you know
about so either way we're attacking a
bunch of debt and we're going to try to
stockpile as much money as we can uh
which is going to help if he starts
working soon and i'm happy to talk to
him whether he wants to call this show
or call my show or you can talk to him
through or we can talk you can talk to
him via me and george here but this is
not the season to wait for the dream job
he needs to get his butt to get to work
okay he's run the family into a
significant financial hole
and i'm proud of the the growth he's
done i'm proud of the healing he's done
he needs to get his butt to work he
needs to start making a lot of money
right
what is your current household income
um
i i went full time this year i was i was
going with my kids but right now i'm
still homeschooling but just not doing
it very well
um i'm gonna make about a hundred
thousand this year and that's a
significant increase well that's great
news i was hoping you had a big shovel
because you got a big mess to clean up
what does child care look like
um well he's been child care so when
because i'm a nurse so i can work odd
hours so we're still going to tag team
and just be home with the kids because
we don't live close to any town okay so
it's hard to get child care can you work
any double shifts over time anything
like that
oh yeah because i think your income
right now with the way you can ramp it
up is going to be more helpful than
anything he could bring in for the short
term right hey marcy can i can i
poke on something for a second
sure
you're still carrying this family right
now
yeah
that's getting real real heavy isn't it
it's been heavy for so long i just don't
even know what to do with it i mean it's
just it just is there's it is you're
right and you've done what you had to do
but when he said can i come back and you
said yes and it's going to be different
and this is what i need and he said i'm
all in you haven't held him to that
standard
is that fair
that's fair you've given him a lot of
grace to heal which is
great now it's time for him to take a
significant chunk of the burden you've
been carrying for a long long time
cool yeah
yes cool okay
conflict deferred is conflict amplified
okay stop being a peacekeeper now now
that he's out of school he's going to
get his butt into work and he's going to
get a job he's going to be a contributor
to this family which by the way is going
to significantly aid in his healing down
the road
but it's time to stop talking it's time
to stop
high-fiving it's time to get to work get
a big mess to clean up